et beau gosse vous à l'étude devant gear
dans les différentes vidéos regardez-moi
ça change confié gauthier moi mon pays
ch'ti mots je vous emmène aujourd'hui
avec moi devant mon centres de jeux
virtuels là et virtuels virtual center
j'ai pas encore chez nous pour vous
parler de pop culture alors je sais ça
n'a strictement rien à voir comme ça
mais c'est pourtant le lieu qui
accueille aujourd'hui l'époque culture
diaries c'est l'édition numéro deux
faisaient présenté la première édition
il ya quelques mois d'ailleurs je vous
invite à aller voir la vidéo si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas et aujourd'hui on va les
découvrir pleins d'autres boîtes de pop
culture plein d'objets plein de trucs de
la musique c'est vachement intéressant
plein de boîtes que j'ai pas rencontrés
dans la première édition celle de la
première édition qui sont également
présentes là je vous envie d'aller la
voir ce ma vidéo de la première édition
justement bien les croire
[Musique]
salut à toi tu travailles beaucoup je
travaille pour une box
ouais il si une entreprise et d box par
abonnement ok on a un abonnement
classique fonctionnant à moi de
l'abonnement on propose depuis quatre
ans maintenant avec en fonction d'un
thème et licences à l'intérieur étaient
produits officiels donc là par exemple
le thème c'est des tyrannies non qu'il y
avait une vie disney du mario du joker
après ça on a un autre abonnement qui
lui 100% avec hauteur lui pareil on veut
avoir son gouverneur dans des produits
officiels pareil des t-shirts des
figurines là un autre bouquin pinera est
aussi un autre type de polypes ont fait
céder box forcé les cadres 1% sur une
licence favorite de nos abonnés donc la
fin du temps on va sortir une bonne
batman bientôt frôle les 80 ans de la
licence
on a déjà des jeux harry potter league
of legends est ici c'est ma dernière box
qui dit laporte
2 décembre sur dragon ball z avec une
petite boule de cristal à l'érable sait
combien une box vous le ventre alors la
place écrivain euros plus les frais de
port bravo plus concrète porte pandraud
par mois auxquels à l'abonnement harry
potter c'est un bimestriel on est tous
les deux mois et c'est 40 euros plus les
frais de port sont plutôt produits et
ses flux des produits plus qu'elle te
plus meilleure qualité ok voilà et la
cellule tout derniers abonnements c'est
un abonnement 100% manga qui va
s'appliquer à ce que ma boxe et à
l'intérieur il y aura pour une
quarantaine d'euros une figurine peinte
cristaux à un tee shirt un manga et des
sacs
[Musique]
seul jérémy comté qui fait quoi alors
moi c'est fait que ça regarde on ferait
des bornes arcades
le plongeur type on intègre des systèmes
d'arcade dans mes bonnes choses par
exemple une caisse de munitions de
l'armée française dans d'autres systèmes
comme un tonneau de vin
mais aussi une série de bornes arcades
par top produit en série d'accord on
peut beaucoup et où du coup on est des
bons les bornes donc on en retrouve dans
des bars sur paris au player one
on est aussi aux barbies l'one et trois
pièces cuisine
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme jeu dont 7
s'est lâchement retro gaming commencé
voilà nous on est vraiment dans la
tribune y en avait jusqu'à plusieurs
milliers toujours même si on veut ouais
c'était donc un c'est vraiment que les
jours notre enfance et street fighter
mortal kombat pacman en compagnie de
tous les citer ok c'est une tu me paraît
alors que si on veut on peut le louer
on peut l'acheter aussi également
exactement tout type de location
la location à la journée au week end et
moi-même longue durée pour toute l'année
arkema la rentrée post ok on peut vous
retrouver où on est sur facebook voile
instagram sur twitter nous avons
aussitôt ci ou par là notre site 5-4
[Musique]
julien équipe qui fait quoi alors je
l'appelle le magot sur internet et je
suis chanteur et guitariste du groupe
magouilles au hockey qui sort son nouvel
album
demain le 17 avril là alors on embauche
de m'expliquer ce qu'on fait comme
musique
ouais en fait du monster métal ou du
rock zombie ce que vous voulez qu'on en
gros c'est qu'on chante des chansons sur
la fin du monde les monstres et les
zombies du métal sont en voie ça chante
en français et c'est du métal qui
racontent plein de plein d'histoires
voilà alors des histoires heureusement
une idée d'histoire
par exemple on va parler de zombies on
va te parler de cirque ambulant on va te
parler de vampires qui meurent qui
vivent des gens des survivants au doux
son de nicole chantons qu'on sait tout
ça sur le web ça dans le même univers
c'est important alors le même univers
exactement c'est c'est quoi l'idée du
projet les bases solides laval s'était
créé notre propre univers et de le
référencer avec plein de choses de la
pop culture soit des films sur les
comics que ce soit des histoires super
connu des coups et que tous nous décrit
dévoile enfin plein de choses de tous m
et de tout transformer et d'adapter sa
lexus
ok on peut vous pouvez vous sur
magazine.com sur tous les réseaux
sociaux possibles et imaginables sur
google+ mais pourquoi et sinon
l'album sur spotify deezer toutes les
plates formes de téléchargement et
évidemment sur notre site web et sinon
on est en concert verdot bientôt tout ça
alors écho et merveilles à toulouse
c'est le 29 avril
mais avant on sera à 3 et légendes la
halle à la fin de la semaine qui est le
17 19 19 avril
j'ai pour une bongo mais je suis fatigué
mais sinon la vraie date c'est le 30 le
30 mai à paris salut a tous entendu
parler de rustiques alors rustique pour
faire très très vite c'est un parc
d'immersion médiéval fantastique
d'accord ça veut dire quoi partie
d'immersion ça veut dire que tous les
visiteurs sont en costume médiéval
ils viennent vivre une aventure qu'ils
ont choisie dans un lot de 150 quelle
mesure et on a cinquante personnages sur
le barde qui sont là pour leur faire
vivre leurs aventures l'organe
c'est une aventure sur la journée sur la
journée sur deux jours d'accord tu n'es
vous avez réseauter le site moins qu'il
ya deux jours on a trois hôtels qui
offre trois types de logements
différents noms comme une auberge un
fort bon ben on est sous tente et un
bâtiment vikings medac moi je veux venir
avec mes potes vous faire une quête sur
la journée j'arrive
j'arrive comme ça la planche je me
présente bonjour qu'est ce qui se passe
alors réservé en avance sur internet
enfin les préventes début de cette année
ok tu réserves son aventure tu réserves
ta place des places tu nous donnes ta
taille des costumes pour que les mets de
côté
oui et puis pas qu'il ya sur place et
c'est parti était la chaîne dans notre
univers est en fait pas souvent quand
j'arrive sur place comment commence
l'aventuré commence à l'anti scénario
gauche qui le rend compte de ce qu'ils
ont choisi on commence laventure déjà
dans le prieuré on est accueilli par les
moines qui vous met qui te donnes ton
costume qui te font le brief de tout ça
et tu es lâché je me lâche et tu rentres
dans le village du département le
village tué le forgeron qui tape sur le
sujet au marteau avec son marteau pardon
et suivantes inquiète
eh bien tu vas aller voir les
protagonistes les personnes qui ont
besoin de toi quand tu es là pour les
aider et humaines en aventure attention
tu peux aller parce que malheureusement
tous les lieux ne faut pas sécurisé le
graveleux nombreuses histoires cours sur
des créatures dans nos bois comme tu
peux choisir de faire aussi bien le bien
que le mal
le orienté complètement le jeu 2-2 avec
tu as la possibilité de venir à
détrousser les voyageurs ont pour moi
même ça va le problème c'est que les
lieux ne sont pas aussi
les choses ne sont pas aussi simples
il peut bien imaginer qui effectivement
si on sait qu'une bande de brigands road
on risque de d'ameuter la milice lagarde
et puisqu'il va avec
nous avions alors c'est un pack qui pend
encore ouvert aujourd'hui 2021 c'est nos
mains c'est demain ça va très très vite
et on peut réserver dès maintenant et
attend encore un petit peu mais avant la
fin de l'année télé sur les réseaux
sociaux tu auras toutes les informations
donc une fois nous suivre face book
rustique par d'immersion ok on
communique plusieurs fois par semaine
génial et le lieu se trouve ou alors
juste à côté de paris 2h30 de paris sait
rien ouais dans l'orne
ok donc côté d'une petite ville qu'on
appelle ses et c'est un lieu magique
vous allez sur youtube tapez partie
version verrait la vidéo le site
internet du parquet génial ras tout est
au top
on a une équipe au top il y en a des
gens motivés roll tué organisatrice des
peuples tour d'alsace facile mon âge
allongé non ça se passe bien ça se passe
très bien
tant culture dice deuxième édition et
cette fois j'ai associé à ça
mouais et très de capitaine du navire co
organisateur d'événements exactement
comment ça se passe cette deuxième
édition
ça se passe très bien je te joindre
rapport à l'année dernière quand je
perds encourageants pourraient tous
exposants aussi peur boombox qui est
venu le parc de gn rustique aussi c'est
ce qu'on appelle un peu love et on a des
journalistes de tous bords qui
annonceurs les médias sont contents pas
mal de rencontres des échanges de cartes
de visite est venu c'est ce qu'on vend
pas tomber facile t'attendant ça permet
effectivement aux explosions dans
l'univers pop d'avoir en relation avec
les médias et vous fait le lien en fait
c'est cool deuxième édition nouveau lieu
l'idée d'avoir changé du lieu qu'ils
voient pour avoir plus grand pour plus
grand et en fait on propose en plus une
activité vers l'est ça c'est bien parce
que plus vieux aussi plus souvent haidar
est une galerie donc on va y avait
beaucoup de choses à vendre alors là en
plus de la vmc encore plus immersif
quand les gens magistrats qui vont les
personnes qui connaissent pas tous comme
on situer ce que sont les peaux plus tôt
alors ces deux journées btu presse donc
on apprend à vivre
à venir rencontrer des exposants de la
structure du jeu vidéo s'appelle de
l'animé du manga d'édition et l'idée
c'est qu'il ya une rencontre que c'est
le project soit développée du secteur
porteur de projet puisse rencontrer la
presse et avoir une exposition
médiatique est en stand préféré toi ça
c'est vraiment la question un peu pourri
alors moi je fais ça non en fait
et je parle dans la vidéo de ce ton bon
j'ai pas parlé à la première édition
alors je vous invite à aller voir la
première vidéo vous retrouvez des
acteurs qui sont déjà présents aussi au
jour enfin qu'ils sont présents
également aujourd'hui ici moi j'aime
bien les petites bornes marcal là parce
que ouais flex c'est une entreprise
française ils font tout eux-mêmes ils
intègrent du retrogaming d'ondés dans
des trucs assez assez assez dingue c'est
vachement bien à la metal slug là
tony est sauvage fort bien le parc
d'attractions sera encore par la
fraction parc d'énergie au parc
d'immersion ouvrir en 2021 en normandie
se trouvent que le projet fou le stic le
projet il faut la faire ou à la rue st
ica suivait ça ça va être incroyable ce
side assez dingue en fait jamais aussi
la livebox gérant jérôme bonnefoi croûte
box fachos ça vachement bien dans les
différents univers donc ça s'est super
bien alors soit on est fan soi même et
on va s'y faire plaisir et de prendre
notre propre box soit sinon pour
l'offrir à des personnes qui sont fans
de l'univers
c'est vraiment génial tu t'es pas
obligée forcément t'abonner tu peux
prendre juste à la boxe dragons prennent
la grosse montréal complexe
harry potter ils ont plein de des
thématiques les musulmans ne sais qu'il
va y avoir les avengers gros ce n'est
pas culturel en termes de cinéma donc
gros ce n'est pour culture chez vous de
boxe en regard de vote à ses heures donc
là on est sur la deuxième édition je
suppose qu'ils auraient une proche d'une
édition on a eu lieu pas encore mais on
va l'annoncer normalement la semaine
prochaine et donc c'est chaud chaud
chaud bouillant est-ce qu'on va changer
dans groupe a déjà scindé les minots
boxer monde parlait d'actes non valises
annoncé la semaine prochaine on n'est
pas encore sûr sur le
merci guillon merci à toi c'est quoi
demain c'est sûr mais ouais on se revoit
de moi et puis on se revoit aussi en
quelques mois pour les prochaines fois
plus tu aurais exactement j'aurais pas
forcément le costard et progressent sauf
si vous avez plus de voir guillaume
différentes vidéos
regardez-moi ça change profitez-en c'est
beau tu es beau mon fils thibault bon
merci zizou stop
non